but you know the epicenter of the
football universe yesterday was Dallas
or whatever city down there they put the
Stadium in Arlington or wearing or
wherever it is the Cowboys hosting the
bills after maximum pressure had been
applied to Jason Garrett in the
aftermath of the loss to the Patriots
the Cowboys surely we're gonna deliver
right right I mean we've seen Jason
Garrett backed against the wall before
and the Cowboys always deliver they
didn't deliver they failed they failed
miserably against the bills the bills
are nine and three the Cowboys are six
and six the Cowboys looked awful they
got a score early to go up seven nothing
and then they just kind of checked out
after that I don't want to say they quit
but boy there were periods in the fourth
quarter big cat where I looked at that
team and I thought do they really care
about this one yeah it was a bizarre
showing from the Cowboys because I think
like everyone they thought okay Jerry
Jones calls out Jason Garrett this is
going to be a galvanizing moment for the
Cowboys they obviously have a ton of
talent on that roster dak Prescott at
times this year has been in the MVP
discussion and then they just laid an
egg right after that first drive like
you said they laid an egg they were able
to move the ball all day they missed
field goals they went for it on fourth
down by the way how perfect is that the
Jason Garrett goes for it on fourth down
twice I think in the first half alone
yesterday as a reactionary move to being
called too conservative in New England
just a week ago and that actually proves
the point even more that he's not doing
it when you're supposed to do it he's
just doing it when he's told to do it
and when the media says hey be a little
bit more aggressive so Jason Garrett is
clearly on his last days in Dallas I you
know Jerry Jones saying he's not gonna
make a change because he thinks that the
team will be better with Jason Garrett
this year than without him I actually
tend to agree I think when you switch a
coach this late in the season you were
funny you were giving up on the season
and the Cowboys still have the chance to
win a game in Philadelphia and win a
couple more games get to the playoffs
but man what a mess going forward for
the Dallas Cowboys yeah big cat I got
some thoughts on that but let's hear
straight from the man himself not Jason
Garrett but the guy who's really in
charge of the Cowboys owner Jerry Jones
saying after the game that despite the
embarrassing loss at home on
Thanksgiving there will not be a
coaching changes Jerry Jones this is not
the time for me I'm looking at another
ballgame and I'm looking ahead it went
in for five straight five straight and
helping write a story that they'll talk
about hat looks like you were down lad
and got it I mean that that's the way
that a hopper ate every decision that I
make over the next month okay that makes
sense and I get it and I really do
believe that the stuff he said Sunday
and when he didn't back off Tuesday that
was all about trying to to cajole
something out of the Cowboys to pull the
cord on the lawnmower that just doesn't
want to start and that was his strategy
to put Jason Garrett in the crosshairs
cuz it's worked in the past when he's
been under pressure well now it didn't
work and now he falls back to well we
have zero percent chance of getting to
the Superbowl if we make a coaching
change they're pretty close to zero if
they don't and what it tells me big cat
I think he's got no confidence in any
other member of the staff to take over
and apply the kick in the ass that the
Cowboys need to win enough games in the
final four weeks of the season to hold
on to first place in the NFC East and
it's all gonna come down to week 16
against the Philadelphia Eagles because
the Eagles play five games four of them
are against teams that are two and nine
that cowboys game week 16 is what's
going to be the deciding factor for the
Cowboys getting to the playoffs and
Jerry Jones just simply doesn't believe
that Chris Rashard or Rod Marinelli or
Kellen Moore or anyone else on that
staff could do any better than Jason
Garrett and that that may be the the
most damning indictment that you can
make of a coaching staff generally when
you consider how badly they're doing
with Jason Garrett they don't think
there's anybody on the staff that could
do any better yeah and I actually tend
to agree
remember in you know September when we
had Kellen Moore is the hot new coach
you know in waiting and everyone was
saying look at this offense after they
rattled off wins against the sisters of
the poor in the NFL because that's
really what it comes down to is the
Cowboys have not beaten a quality
opponent all seas
long they beat up on the teams that
they're supposed to beat up and then
when they get tested by a Patriots by a
Bills by a Vikings some of these games
being at home they fall flat on their
face and that's really what it has been
for these Cowboys and dak Prescott you
can show the same thing where I think
he's a very very good quarterback and
he's had a good season but when those
big games come around he doesn't elevate
his play to that next level and possibly
win his team one of these games you know
you saw it last week in Foxborough
obviously that that tripping call was
absolutely bogus and it kind of robbed
us of a moment where dak could maybe go
the length of the field and steal one of
those games but but again dak Prescott
has not done that and Jason Garrett has
not done that and if you're Jerry Jones
what else can you do I mean besides the
very obvious which I don't even want to
mention but the real obvious thing is to
hire a GM and maybe stop making all the
roster decisions yourself but outside of
that because we know that wait a minute
that's a valid criticism 10 years ago
they have compiled an excellent roster
that's the problem Jerry Jones has he's
wanted to be responsible for building a
Super Bowl team and he has they just
can't get to the Super Bowl because of
coaching no I mean it's a it's a it's a
good roster but it clearly has some
holes in it and yeah you're right the
coaching I think a different coach
obviously gets more out of this team so
but the GM I mean I don't know Jerry
Jones to me I when I when I watch that
when I watch them teary-eyed and say
maybe this is gonna be a Super Bowl run
and we're gonna write the history he
looks like me and that's not a good
thing that's not a good thing in the
fact that he's no more than like a dumb
fan just saying there hey look we're not
eliminated yet statistically speaking we
can make a run here when in reality we
all know that's not the case and the
Cowboys have a lot more flaws and have
not proven anything and the best part
about this game Mike is the bills come
in and everyone says the bills myself
included have not beaten anyone
and now with ACO go out with a huge win
on Thanksgiving Day everyone in Buffalo
is happy and they deserve this type of
team and now they basically you know
passed off the narrative to the Cowboys
who they look at you're the Cowboys
schedule say hey wait a second they
haven't beaten anyone either
we're gonna give the bills appropriate
praise in the next segment for now
though to kind of put a button on this
whole cowboys conversation what do you
think Garrett needs to do to save his
job is it salvageable at this point for
anything less than a Super Bowl
appearance or Super Bowl win yeah I
don't think unless they maybe maybe a
close NFC Championship loss would be the
only other thing but I just think at
this point in the NFL you get to a point
where the if the locker room Tunes you
out it's kind of over and doesn't it
feel like that's what's happening here
with this team because if there was ever
a game for the Cowboys to put it all on
the line and stand up and say this is
the game we're gonna change our season
on it would have been yesterday and you
know what credit to dak Prescott who is
making runs at the end of the game where
he was putting his body on the line
trying to get that extra yard trying to
will his team to victory but it feels it
feels like the rest of the team is flat
and I just think once you lose that mic
you can't get that back and Jason
Garrett has been around for a very long
time and if you're if you're a coach for
a very long time it's the old Phil
Jackson rule of seven you know after
seven years guys tuned you out and it's
hard to keep people motivated the same
way as year two three four five what
enlist all of them so I think Jason
Garrett sit in that spot right now where
it's gonna be very very hard for him to
recapture the faith in the locker room
and the understanding that he's putting
his guys in the best position to win
football games
because I don't think anyone thinks that
right now fans Jerry Jones players
everyone is saying Jason Garrett is not
putting us in the best position to win
on Sunday and this is a conversation
that we'll probably have on future of
Fridays but but give me your knee-jerk
if you're a Cowboys fan who's the guy
you'll want next year who's at the top
of your list Oh
and um all right I'll throw out there
Greg Roman would be probably at the top
my less seeing what he's doing in
Baltimore right now that would probably
be up there can you will some of these
younger college minds which I don't
think we haven't seen it as much
recently where the college coaching you
remember back in the day Mike when it
was it was literally college coach goes
straight to the NFL that was kind of the
transition and it seems to have happened
a little bit less in the last few years
but everyone's gonna throw a Lincoln
Riley out there everyone's gonna say his
name and guess what
even if you want to make your jokes and
say the Dallas Cowboys have not been
relevant in a meaningful football sense
of the term in 25 years and haven't won
big games in 25 years being the head
coach of the Dallas Cowboys still means
something and they will still get the
top of the line coaching candidates when
they do fire Jason Garrett and when they
do go into that coaching pool next year
I got the name to watch I'm not saying
that this is the top candidate or the
best candidate but the name I'm keeping
an eye on is a guy who's currently
coaching a professional football team
that is headquartered in Dallas Bob
Stoops of the XFL is Dallas renegade
that would put the Renegades in quite a
pinch if they lose Bob Stoops a month
before their season begins but that one
is just one of those that if it happened
we'd be like yeah we should have seen
that one coming so let's see it coming
now I'm gonna put my money on Bob Stoops
as the next coach of the Dallas Cowboys
by the time the dust all settles and
that the key is a guy who isn't gonna
kinda try to come in and take over
that's not what Jerry and Steven Jones
want that's one of the reason why Jason
Garrett's still there they've done it
with Jimmie Johnson they've done it with
Bill Parcells they want to still be the
center of the universe not the coach and
so the coach who signs on is gonna have
to accept that and Bob Stoops would have
to be okay with that and if he's
upgrading from the Dallas renegades to
the Dallas Cowboys maybe he will
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports